if I was to say one bad thing about
arcad it would be the simple fact that
their basic libraries are absolutely
terrible that's why in today's video
we're going to be breaking down the best
add-on library money can buy what's
going on guys my name is David Thomas
I'm a registered architect here in
Western Australia and today we're
talking about the 4D library now I want
to get on the record this video is not
sponsored by 4D Library I have no
affiliation with them I just simply use
their products and think they deserve to
be showcased a little bit more we're
going to break down exactly what is in
the 4D Library what you can use and
enhance your documentation with and what
I personally use and how I use it let's
start by actually figuring out how you
download 4D Library it's incredibly
simple all you do is jump onto
4dlibrary.com
it is an Australian program it is an
Australian website and it is designed
for the Australian Market hence why I
actually use it so much and genuinely
really love it now the 4D Library
website in full disclosure is pretty
basic it is pretty boring it is very
very technical it is not something
you're going to jump on and go to wow
this is the best website I've ever seen
but you're only there to get the core
information download the library and get
out the 4D library is updated every
single year and continues to get updated
every couple of months as the owner
continues to work on it if you go to key
features up top you'll see it's been
running for a very very long time and it
is continuing to be updated in all of
these sections across 20 different
components I believe if you actually
want to download the four day library
and purchase it when you go across to
purchase you have to actually email the
company and set up your profile and
everything through them directly rather
than on the website as a direct purchase
so overall the subscription plan start
at 650 per year per license which isn't
a huge amount when you're working in a
big firm but it might be quite a large
amount if your work is a small firm but
overall generally that is the very
basics of the 4D library and now I think
it's time to actually dive in to what
the four day library is capable of so if
we jump into arcad 25 and load up the
current version of the 4D Library it's
not going to look any different to
anything else until you start actually
going into these objects so if we'll
start with doors for example doors is
one of my most used categories of the
four day Library it has a number of
items that are just significantly better
than the standard arcade doors there are
still some things that the arcad doors
do better like screening options and
louvers over top but the 4D Library does
an overall better user experience and it
is simply easier to use from a general
day-to-day practice if we start with the
external multi-doors example it will
give you some very simple overall door
styles you can change how the overall
leaf looks an immense amount of ways and
you can basically work through all of
these settings to make this door
customized exactly how you like it so
let's say we want a glass door instead
and we want to highlight over the top
everything is automatic parametric and
super simple to use if we continue to
quickly flick through these objects and
settings you can see that the frames are
thicker you can adjust side light sizes
sash sizes you can customize the side
light you can add all sorts of different
silk settings seal profiles Corner
settings we can even go into some great
architectural hinges and door details
even creating your own custom handles so
we can just continuously make this door
look exactly like it would be on site
and document it 100 correctly we also
have the garage door which is an
extremely useful feature because the
garage door provides multiple options as
well as panel Styles so let's say we
didn't want a four panel we wanted a
plane door or we wanted some windows at
the top all of these changes are so
simple materials we can even quickly
change and that way if we wanted to
change anything we don't really have to
go too deep into the settings personally
4D doors is definitely one of the best
things about the 4D Library as well as
the 4D windows so if we jump into the 4D
Windows you'll see there's a variety of
different window Styles in a recent
update they launched this Jason
residential windows Suite which is one
of the largest Australian manufacturers
of Windows personally we don't use Json
Windows too often so we don't actually
use that feature it is a very good
feature it does showcase all of their
Styles built in in the configuration
modes updated into it so if you were
using Json Windows it would be so easy
to use and so simple to document what we
do use instead is a multi-layered 4D
window and a layered four-day window
which basically allows you to create any
architectural style of window you're
looking for without having to create
multiple windows you can just simply
have one and then one on the Windows
schedule sliding doors as well have some
great features in them again all of
these settings are completely not
correct they've just been dumped into a
random file so these would come up
properly if you were to actually import
this Library properly but the sliding
doors have some immense features so for
example you can very quickly and rapidly
adjust this door and have it slide in
any direction that you want increase the
overall width of the door within seconds
autumn automatically customized to
bridge sizing or to whatever you've
defined as a custom size again we have a
very similar settings that we had in
those previous door settings where we
can increase highlights introduce them
have we see fit introduce side lights if
we wanted to and just keep this door
going to the exact specification we
really really need what you'll also
notice in one of the corner settings is
if we change this to a 90 degree corner
you automatically get a silicon joint so
you tick that box it takes away the
column and you're able to create a
silicon joint in your corner so easily
without having to fluff around with all
of the other parametric settings I did
mention previously that one of the
drawbacks of this is it doesn't come
with any external shading it does
however come with internal blinds and
roller shutters now both those items are
relatively standard relatively basic if
you're an arcad user you may or may not
have noticed this desk map behind me the
desk mat is basically an arcad shortcut
cheat sheet printed directly on your
desk so you will never ever forget the
best the arcad shortcuts to make your
workflow significantly easier the desk
mat is designed with mac and PC
shortcuts directly inputted depending on
your preference it comes in three colors
and two Styles so be sure to check it
out at davidcomich.com it's when we dive
in to the arcad objects library and look
at the 40 Library itself that we see in
these huge improvements in to what this
product can actually produce so if we
jump into object and open up the object
settings tool you'll see we have our 4D
Library already Linked In if I quickly
run through all of these objects to show
you what they can do I'm going to point
out what I use specifically and why so
in the site and Landscaping tool you'll
see a number of objects available to you
one of the best objects is a simple
North tool because it's so much better
than the standard arcad available the
cones of vision and the cutoff drain are
also incredibly helpful when you're
documenting our codes and you're going
through planning processes so both of
these are used and they are quite
helpful the 4D library has its own
scheduling for its doors and windows you
can still introduce them back into the
arcad schedules and you can use these
schedules individually it just really
depends what your preference is and how
you want to go about scheduling the
balustrating and fencing tool has been
incredibly useful if I'm being
completely honest the 4D balance trade
is Miles Ahead of the actual
balustrating tool available in our CAD
just for its Simplicity not for anything
else colorbond fence is obviously one of
the most common fences in Australia so
having that tool available to you is
again very very user friendly and very
easy the arcad 4D staircase is again
something that I prefer over the arcad
default the staircase once again just so
much easier to use so much more
user-friendly and you can document
exactly what you need without having to
go through 600 different million options
everything is linked to Australian
standards you don't have to consider
risers and runs you can simply type in
let's say that's going to rise two
meters is it going to be compliant not
really so let's drop that down to 10
stairs is it going to be comply clients
still no jump to 11 yes we're now
compliant accessories into concrete
masonry these we don't go into too much
personally because we tend to use the CI
tools instead of the 4D library for the
coverings and wall claddings it's just
more so because that's how the temp has
been set up for so long rather than
anything else however they do have the
roof covering accessories and they do
have the cornices and the four day
Corner accessories in addition you have
even more roof tools like a cool a
bullnose Veranda 4D in the country a lot
of people want steel bullnose Verandas
so this is just so complicated to create
in arcad whereas it is an automatic
object and the parametrics just make
everything so simple there is cranked 4D
beams for all of your cranked roofs
there is pfcs there's multi-gables all
of these which we use the 4D u-beams and
the full finial sets there's some
amazing Little Gems hidden in the roof
that we definitely use in practice a lot
skylights and solar tubes I don't tend
to use the 4D solo tube too often and I
do use more so the 4D Skylight library
but these turbo vents for example are a
great addition to any roof plan roof
planning again 4D libraries down pipes
rain heads soak Wells and rainwater
tanks all get used quite often the rain
head in particular is a great object
jumping ahead a little bit further to
wall trims the four day awning is an
incredible tool it is something that we
use in practice all the time some of
these others not so much the 4D data
tool can be used for window surrounds
very simply very easily and it is rarely
and seldom used but it is still used
every now and again the cabin tree is
where four-day Library does tend to
shine again I know icad has stepped up
their game in 25 and again in 26 to be
able to produce a better Cabinetry but
4D still does it so much better we have
all of our default Cabinetry set up by
4D Library themselves so you don't have
to tweak too much like for example you
have a full microwave recess and just
like every other 4D Library tool all of
their settings so easy to use you don't
have to worry about trying to figure out
what everything is how it works you just
simply click through the animated
pictures and make it exactly how you
need it to be the 4D Cabinetry continues
there's a lot more features in that
there's compound cabin trees there's
accessories and appliances connected to
it the appliances again do get used
quite often the four day dishwasher is a
beautiful object as you can see the
ovens the hot plates the microwaves the
stoves all of this does get used in
practice and they are all better than
arcad defaults the electro fixtures and
fittings get used here and there the
electrical schedule is quite good it
just takes a little bit of time to get
used to and break down and understand
their custom tools for actually
documenting double GPO single gpos and
everything to Australian standards is
phenomenal so it does and will get used
if you download it now Plumbing fixtures
in 4D Library are significantly Superior
for example the multi 4D shower is one
of the best shower objects I've ever
found for archicad there is no not a
better object on the market that I've
used or experienced and that this object
alone will make your drawings
significantly better on plan compared to
any shower available in arcad it gets
into the ingredient as well for the
accessories like the toilet roll holder
and the mirrors which are all very
useful and as well with the nitty-gritty
in the 2D detailing the remainder of
this section is very much about the
architectural documentation and the
construction detailing going into your
2D symbols and your calculators many of
which don't get used in practice for me
because it's more so about the CI tools
and the Keynotes but they're still
available as a full all-in-one Library
package from 4D the standard notes again
just something that you can add as are
the zones and labels as well as allowing
you to create custom components like
this Rondo sync the last available
folder in 4D library is 30.0 macros
which is basically a behind the scenes
folder that allows 4D library to operate
properly and you do not basically have
to utilize or look into that folder ever
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video check out the playlist
to the side of me for more great
architectural content if you love the
video make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and don't forget about
the like button as well every little bit
helps with the YouTube algorithm anyway
for now I'll see you next Monday